this arid landscape in northern kenya is
part of the greater horn of africa
that's experiencing its worst drought in
decades
as a result more than 1.7 million
children are suffering from the most
lethal form of malnutrition
we're hungry because we have nothing to
eat we only eat these wild berries we
have no livestock we have nothing we
depend on the trees where we collect
wild berries that's our food
the situation is being made worse by
conflict thousands of kilometers away
this life-saving supplement known as a
power pace can mean the difference
between life or death
in a place where aid workers say young
children are dying in near famine-like
conditions
invented a quarter of a century ago a
single sachet delivers 500 calories of
essential nutrients allowing
malnourished children to quickly regain
energy and weight
but the conflict in ukraine has affected
the cost and availability of the
life-saving peanut paste as well as the
means to deliver it to those who
desperately need it children die as a
result of malnutrition the effects of
drought
three years down the line no rain
so this one is life-saving
without this
mochi they will die
the timing could not be worse unicef
which buys nearly 80 of the world's
supply of these supplements expects the
cost to rise to 12 million dollars more
than when the war began
and with donations to deal with the food
shortage crisis here falling far behind
many say more needs to be done to help
the millions of people in the horn of
africa
jillian wolf al jazeera